today's question comes from david and
george i'm 32 years old and i'm on baby
step 7.
whoa way to go david i've been
disciplined and
intense with money since i was 18 years
old i am feeling
very all caps discouraged
knowing that i'm fighting this whole
thing single-handedly how can i be
intentional about meeting someone to
marry
oh david wants to get hitched that's a
loaded question that we could literally
take
a full show to answer yeah i would love
to talk to david here
sometimes people get so
intense about goals and objectives yep
they then want to use that same energy
and model for human connection
and anytime a person yeah becomes a goal
or a strategy or an objective you've
devalued that relationship and that's
not somebody who has any business
marrying you
and you shouldn't marry them yeah right
so
for somebody who is hyper goal driven
hyper outcome focused human
relationships are going to be
challenging
right um what do you think ken
well the question is how can i be
intentional about meeting someone
to marry put yourself in situations
where you're going to meet people so i
wrote this book called the proximity
principle that had nothing to do with
marriage but it applies here as well the
proximity principle
came from the show when i just started
giving people advice on how to get where
they want to go
and it simply says this in order to do
what you want to do you got to be around
people that are doing that
in places where it is happening so if
you want to get intentional about
meeting people to marry
you start going what's the type of woman
i want to marry
you know don't turn it into a giant
checklist like john saying
however you can say hey i want to meet
this type of woman who maybe has these
values and guess what once we have a
general idea of what we're looking for
in a life mate
then we know where those people are see
before that i want him to i love the
idea of proximity
i want him just to start hanging out
with people well i think he probably is
you think so yeah it's hard to read into
this question here's my point
you want to meet women then where are go
be around women type of women
yeah it's like uh here's the here's one
idea just be a normal human being
and hang out with other people in groups
to i think that's what you're saying
and then if you see a woman that is
attractive to you uh you'll be a
gentleman
and you ask them out and if she says no
don't go back to your cave and suck your
thumb
do it again and eventually someone will
say yes
and then be a gentleman and keep doing
it until finally john
tada the light bulb goes off let's not
overthink this how do i be intentional
to meet somebody be intentional meet
women don't be a creeper and uh
be clear on what you think you want your
wife
to uh be like sound like act like
whatever you just have to
that other people want to be in
partnership with be a person who's
yeah shows up and is safe and is
kind and treats people with dignity and
is respectful
be a person that someone wants to
connect with yeah and david you know
what i
i'm feeling this was a little bonus
advice
what's the bonus i'm reading into this
we got to be fair folks we have limited
information here it's not a caller i
think david needs to be careful on date
number one
not to like do a full expose on these
gals finances
he's intense yeah don't talk about your
money man yeah chill out on the money
right now
because you're you're in baby step seven
you're in good shape you can do this
but does it make sense what i'm saying
eventually if he meets somebody
and asks them out and the goal of this
is not
to get to know somebody to hang out and
to have some laughs
right to learn about somebody the goal
is to begin
running the algorithm of this person
yeah not a good idea no
no you're gonna scare girls scare them
you're gonna melt people
yeah and you're very that you put here
in all caps is gonna get bigger and
bigger and bigger your discouragement is
gonna get more frustrating
meet people for the sake of meeting
people be with people for the sake of
being
people and from that you'll develop
relationships with folks that will turn
into something bigger and better than
that
yeah and you know what go read some
books on some older classic books on
what it means to be a gentleman if i was
going to give advice to any young dude
these days i'd go you know what
i don't care what the world's telling
you i don't care what culture has become
i'm telling you be a gentleman what does
that mean
to me yeah well when it relates to
relating to women it's
first and foremost you may be attracted
to them but you still must respect them
treat them open their car door listen to
them
you know value them don't just be
attracted to them they're not an
object they are a beautiful part of this
world and so being a gentleman
is kind respectful thoughtful
uh not selfish with women in every
aspect i'll just leave it at that i
think it's pretty obvious yeah
but i i think it's obvious i don't know
that a lot of young 20 somethings
think about what it means to be a
gentleman and how you treat
women i love it a lot of the garbage
that's going on in the world
if even if you're unhealthy but if you
go you know what i got to be a gentleman
yeah i got to be a gentleman like dads
if we were teaching our boys to be
gentlemen
a lot of stuff going on between the
sexes
would not be as gross if we were just
treating each other with dignity right
this is the standard yeah
i'm gonna be a gentleman it starts um
with young people watching their parents
treat each other right that's right and
talk to each other with dignity and
treat each other with respect
and not throwing temper tantrums and
adults throw temper tantrums and
treating each other with yeah with
utmost dignity and respect
and kids learn by watching man yeah yeah
but we have long since gotten over the
art form of just teaching manners and
just
how do you just treat people so i know
i'm old school in it right now but there
it is old school too